I agree yes you do right whatever you
just say exactly I said action oh so I'm
glad you agree I disagree disagree okay
boy because you agree mm-hmm I'm gonna
ask you a question
thank you when you are running late in
the morning to go somewhere run late
I do sometimes sometimes you do when
you're running late
what is the very like your top priority
thing to skip check it off
oh of your morning routine oh that
that's hot will you skip no that's what
makes you leave Dean that I skip cuz
you're a very systematic guy so I know
you definitely have a routine a routine
that's like solid I don't honestly I
don't think I skip anything because I'm
like [ __ ] just do everything faster yeah
and my routine is already fast like if I
yeah I can go from waking up to brush my
teeth to taking a shower to eating like
I don't know a protein shake to being in
the car in like under 10 minutes yeah I
might not do my hair like I'll put a hat
on oh yeah that's not maybe that yeah
but I had to brush my teeth
yeah I might skip my poops in the
morning sometimes I can you do this the
morning ADIZ well sometimes it's not
ready
oh ripe enough you know and then I'm
like oh maybe once I drink coffee you
know I'll help sometimes it's just it's
shy and just clenched harder well yeah
but then you're sitting on the toilet
you're like [ __ ] I'm like it's getting
closer to that man you know the man it's
just really stressful and the more
stressful it is the less likely the poop
didn't come out so I just get the poop
all the other sometimes that's what
makes me late what happened after though
because you refuse to poop anywhere
other than at home
yeah like earlier after lunch okay I
think I'm just finally ready because
this morning was one of those morning's
where I'm like skip the poop and you had
a turtle head i sat down the bathroom
and no one getting a quite tip turtle
head yeah it was just like not even that
yet so I'm like whatever do you get
travel cost with constipation al oh you
do all the time one of those well I'm
going to this pull here well I found out
what I skip what
working out you skip right that's like a
one or two hour window right so it's
actually a huge chunk so usually I do a
lot of time for a workout whether it's a
right John or whatever I'm like Vanessa
the comedy part yeah the cop is like
about an hour or two for comedy in the
morning and so sometimes if I wake up
late or my alarm doesn't go off or
something oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna [ __ ] it and then I'll skip the
jokes they're not that important cuz
according to this survey here people
like the very first thing like the
majority of people what they skip when
they're running late is making their bed
at 56% I don't even know such boys cuz I
can't like actually today we didn't make
the bed I sorta got for like two weeks
straight you just don't like I said on
the couch oh do you make the couch yeah
what the pills need to be fluff do you
have any pillows blankets Bo why keep my
room pretty clean like a girl and see if
she says that's why the groom's cleaned
oh oh cuz he has no girls that's so he's
on the couch
please getting it ready it's the girl
vision is way different in guy vision
you could think it's clean a girl be
like oh hell no closet but perfect kind
of not really boys a gun might fall
somewhere like see the floor of your
closet yeah yeah being like it is all
covered it's not clean at all huh
everything to make your car is not clean
you sure yeah Kara with guys pretty good
guy just clean I clean is different than
girls way that's so true a girl's car
can be horrible yeah girls car look at
my car well yours different you are on
an illegitimate vomit in there for the
year what
what was that they were cleaning out
that one time I was like melted beef
chow fun or some [ __ ] beef
oh yeah in your Ted the [ __ ] love the
leftover food
like vomit now yeah you're right this
[ __ ] laptop still smells cuz it was
in there but that was not my fault she
was supposed take out the food
I was his job it was no yeah it was his
food cuz he was like okay I will take a
nap no it's cuz it's in the front so I
never see it oh yeah did I even all use
it all that often
it was stuck in there for what two weeks
yeah do you guys have a bad making rule
that who makes the bed yeah there is a
rule it is being complied who's that
what's the role now cuz our role is who
leaves the bed last relates the bed is
kind of cool cuz I'm all our rule is
whoever's out of the bed first needs to
make your half first your half and then
there's no wait throw the president
that's one that was my apparently
there's no gentle way to do your bad way
yeah because no this was like hugging
this is all you gotta do like just pull
it lightly and if it's not perfect it's
okay it's my problem at the end of like
I'm the one that's the last person to
get out of bed so I will finesse it but
you have to make sure to just at least
like just make it tight that's it if
literally making our beds but sometimes
you steal the blanket it's like way on
your side I'm like there's no what's the
purpose of making a bed it does that uh
the brain chemical [ __ ] you went like
completing a task and it's the very
first thing you do in the day and it's
something to like maintain your your
environment it does something to your
brain I'm hella productive and I don't
do that [ __ ] at all imagine how much
more yeah how much more what's less
product okay
how many minutes does it take to make
that bed not even one name less than one
minute takes me five alright cuz I have
to give us point across
that's all waste of time Oh cuz I'm I'm
including the sheep well how many times
you jack off how long does jack off
session that is great do you ever leave
the jacking off out of this I jerk off
to people making bets put a time on
passion okay you can't put a time limit
on art Joe's larks ha jack-in-office all
right hell yeah
did you Jack off while making the bed Oh
cuz you know smear this whole bed
everywhere well did you ever place well
I think use reason to watch it I heard
that like in the morning it's good to
just leave it open because the air it
needs to air out the bed because of the
sweat that can debunk it Wow that whole
argument is literally why you should
make your bed if you make the man it
traps it no no because you're airing
[ __ ] out like what kids [ __ ]
chinese-style like I just let go of the
blanket like that peel it out it's like
a sardine can you unroll that
[ __ ] and then you roll it back
up like a sleeping bag okay well I don't
know I don't have to answer to nobody
but but when I wake up in the morning
the first thing I love to do is to pee
not make up my bed true because I
usually really gotta pee
that is the first thing most people
would agree with that and it helps me
wake up because I just what's your
morning routine then pee I go I pee I
weigh myself I log in how much I weigh
into MyFitnessPal and then I put on my
shorts I put all my tank top and I'd get
my belt and I walk out the door oh no I
drink a whole thing of water twice and
then I walk out and ice and I'm half
asleep walking around the neighborhood
and then I wake up by the time I get to
my garage I work out and that's been my
morning routine that's time it's awesome
this is the recent one then warranty
routine but this one quarantine routine
no coffee no coffee
no and then if I have a little bit more
time I'm meditating and doing breathing
exercises and some stretching that's
been wonderful and
I [ __ ] make my breakfast I pee in the
shower when I wake up that's a nice
shower right huh I'm a night shower I
shot that morning me too
I've been taking baths so nasty that
[Laughter]
dude my morning routine is waking up
being on my phone or now more recently
is the Nintendo switch I don't even
touch my finger they don't like my back
because it makes me productive no how
many beats I'm collecting right now it's
so productive you get it huh you get it
Animal Crossing yeah yeah I've been kind
of addicted for like a solid week it was
bound to happen yeah pretty much said
bye to my wife for the past two weeks
making a bed makes you addicted to video
games making the bad thing for us so
just really quick throwing it in there I
like it because it's kind of like a like
a joined effort like a joint effort you
start the day with a joint effort any
time it's kind of it feels like we're
both making a home kind of you know like
that's the reason for that yeah and it
feels like a team yeah I honestly do
like I didn't does something to
psychology or like every time I come
back in if the bed is it made it does
feel like it's unfinished yeah but when
do you come into a room like just like
how many go into a fresh hotel room when
they do come and make your bed and like
clean up - it feels good so I do like
that feeling that's true cuz if I saw a
really hot girl in lingerie making my
bed I would come home and go boy if you
just saw the hot girl in lingerie would
you say yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
awesome awesome because she was making
the bed this is a the bed could be messy
actually the room could be even more
messy than it is right now if she's
laying there in lingerie
right so you I start between a route I
made room with a made bed with a
lingerie model on top of the bed versus
a dirty-ass room
unmade bed lingerie model on top of that
I don't think he sees anything else
tunnel vision got it that's true cuz I
[ __ ] to go with her doc [ __ ] on the
floor before you still decide that sex
with her yeah you're really good at
focusing that's what I'm saying I got to
me they say you got to be optimistic
right and you got to always see the good
parts
I knew the doc shirt wasn't there by to
see it I focused on the good parts yeah
but when it comes to housekeeping I have
a very interesting relationship because
when I'm folding clothes I love the
smell of the laundry but every minute
that's ticking I feel like I'm losing
money that's true
folding clothes when it's fresh and hot
how does it feels great yeah it's fun to
do but once it's cold and puckish
disgusting it's all wrinkled and [ __ ]
washing dishes that's my wiping the
floors all that stuff like I start
feeling like I'm becoming poorer and
poorer as this is happening Wow but
recently I learned to love it because
it's therapeutic now I know why some
people like cleaning because when you're
doing one task you're focused and it's
kind of soothing because you're cleaning
an egg in a flow state yeah and in my
mind is able to just focus on one
thought sometimes because I'll be
thinking about Oh what should I be doing
what should I be wearing maybe I should
be an assassin one day hmm very
productive you're making money that yeah
I guess so but I would rather hire a hot
girl to do it it's gotta be that's a
senora float clothes Oh both OH don't
know my dears right you should hire that
uh housekeeper like the her they don't
do a good job you knew where I was going
she's in a bikini or any theater yeah I
was the same person doing all the houses
no service but with Cove it'd now I
don't trust these hos where they showed
off the mask
nothing else all right and then I was a
good listicle because we didn't get past
it wait those are mystical
[Music]